dot org you're watching book TV on
c-span - and now joining us live is the
author of flash boys Michael Lewis
what is a flash boy the heroes of the
book and the flash boys and they're
people who discover that the stock
markets got something funny going on it
and go and seek to find out what it is
and then build a mechanism to prevent
predators in the stock market from
getting to prey and it's called the
flash boys for a couple of reasons
actually one one is that the the
solution that the main characters come
up with requires them to be faster than
the high speed traders who are the
predators in the stock market so they've
got to be maybe I wanted speed in the
title but I also wanted kind of
superhero in the title because they were
these I mean these characters at the
center of the story I felt I mean
they're not doing anything unnatural but
they do have these weird powers in the
financial markets right now in the end
the powers are powers to explain
complicated things to people the the
power to kind of engender trust in
others but the last reason it's called
flash boys is I knew I wanted flash in
the title and then when I was because
the markets have taken this term and it
flash crashes and and flash orders its
flash trading and I had a title that was
coming in an irk title I thought I was
gonna call it flat the flash trap I was
driving with my kids in a car one day
and they said what's the book called
that you're working on I said flash trap
and they said that's really dull and I
said well you come up with a better one
and they said what's it about and I said
well it's kind of about these guys on
Wall Street who figure out rich people
on Wall Street are stealing from less
rich people of middle-class people and
they get upset about it
and they try to do something about it
and they go Mike he's go rich people are
stealing from other people I said yeah
it is that's awful well yeah but that's
what's happening he said and they're
gonna fix it I said yeah they're fixing
guess that's like Robin Hood or
something else he's kinda like Robin
Hood and they said one on one of my
children said what'd you call it flash
boys so I thought there's my title I
never told my publisher that where that
came from that's where it came from
how in your view are people stealing
from others on Wall Street
well stealing is it's I think everything
is going on as far as I know it's legal
I don't know if what's going on isn't
illegal illegal but the there's a the
stock exchanges have become unfair
places for investors and it's happened
it's happened pretty rapidly over the
last six seven years where the the the
thirteen public Stocki on the thirteen
public stock exchanges and look they're
all scattered through New Jersey
high-speed traders are provided by the
exchanges for fees for lots of money in
the exchange they've high-speed trains
pay the exchanges for special feeds
which enable them to see movement stock
prices before ordinary investors so they
know it's only a couple of a millisecond
advantage it's the amount of time
involved is very very slight but they
they know where they know today's prices
and we know yesterday's prices and in
the ordinary investor knows yesterday's
prices the analogy is it's a bit like
someone knowing the result of a horse
race before it's been run walking into
the track and starting to be able to bet
with other people who are betting on the
horse race so there is this unfairness
in the in the middle of the system the
so that's that's the that's the problem
and that problem is nobody quite knows
how big the problem is in terms of like
the sums of money that are being
essentially taxed out of investors by
Wall Street intermediaries but it's I
mean it's billions of dollars a year
because of these milliseconds because of
these millisecond all right this is
something you write in your book flash
boys mr. Lewis you write that over the
past decade the financial markets have
changed too rapidly for our mental
picture of them to remain true to life
the picture I'll bet most people have of
the markets is still a picture of a
human being that a human being might
have taken in it a ticker tape runs
across the bottom of some cable TV
screen with alpha males and color-coded
jackets standing in trading pits
hollering at each other that picture is
dated the world it depicts is
yeah in fact that's the picture I kind
of had in my head when I got into this
story I'm I didn't have any great sense
of what had happened the market you
stood there was only three or four years
ago that you started hearing this phrase
high-frequency trading
and it was it's really only in the last
decade that the markets have become
fully automated meaning that all trades
go into are going are essentially
matched inside of computers rather than
human bite by human beings on the stock
exchange and the New York mean it's
funny because it's a problem and it's
also a literary opportunity to describe
but what this new world is but you can
see how how hard it is for people to get
their minds around what not just a stock
market but all the financial markets
have become because they cling to the
old picture you see when you watch the
TV and people and their reports about
what's going on the stock market their
pictures of people on the new york stock
exchange is if those people are actually
at the center of the market still the
old picture is still sort of being being
used because the new picture hasn't been
drawn so one of the things I'd hope to
do it was almost by the by but I thought
it would be is to leave reader with a
sense of a different sort of picture and
but the problem is in order to generate
that mental picture you almost have to
imagine time the way a computer does is
that that's the that's what's happened
is the computer can a computer can jet
can make you know a thousand trades in
the time it takes a human being to make
one computer time it's a bit like
geological time like like the time it
takes to form mountains and valleys and
rivers and it's hard to get your mind
around what can be done in the
millisecond if you were to draw that
picture today Michael Lewis would you
draw it at the New York Stock Exchange
on Wall Street or would you draw it in
Mahwah New Jersey
other so I would draw it in Milan New
Jersey I mean the the exchanges are all
housed in data centers very heavily
guarded data centers in Weehawken
Secaucus Carteret and la WA and New
Jersey and you go in them what you see
is you get their boxes of black boxes
rows and rows of black boxes but one set
of the black boxes is the exchange
itself it's called the matching engine
where the buyers and sellers are
connected and where so where price
discovery happens what the price of a
stock should be because the bride and
the seller agrees to meet at that price
then you have around that matching
engine the boxes of the high frequency
traders who pay fifty thousand dollars a
month
hundred thousand dollars a month
whatever it is to connect a line
directly into the box you get
information about what's happening on
the exchange before everybody else
what is front-running that you talk
about in flash boys so rut ring is the
idea of is like almost like tickets
imagine a ticket scalper or I mean the
someone who figures out that the show is
going to be sold out runs up buys
tickets turns or a heads at the box
office price and turns around it sells
them and you know double the price to
people who walked up to see the show in
the stock market what is what is
happening often is that a faster traders
with faster machines are able to
anticipate orders to buy and sell stock
from investors in every kind of
industrial little investor to big
investor and and buy the stock say
before them and sell it back to them a
slightly higher price and you're talking
about a millisecond one millionth of a
second you know second is a thousand a
thousand to myself every time
microseconds to me actually
high-frequency traders now are making
decisions to improve speeds by
nanoseconds so millisecond and
milliseconds a thousandth of a second a
microsecond is a thousandth of a
millisecond and a nanosecond is a
thousandth of a microsecond so you
taught the increments of speed are
mind-numbing ly small it's very hard but
but my point is that the ability to
divine your intentions and act faster
than you creates this opportunity for
front burning doesn't mean happens every
trade in stock market but I think it
happens quite a lot
what was interesting to me about this
story about this young man this young
Canadian who sort of figures out for
himself what's going on he's a traitor
on Wall Street but he finds himself
being front-run and he can't figure out
quite how people are doing this is that
once he once he figures it out and he
wanders around even the moat the office
of even the most sophisticated investors
in America big hedge fund managers for
example he finds that everybody senses
there's this front-running going on but
nobody knows in the nature of it no one
understands why no one understands in
the plumbing of the market so Bill
Ackman big hedge fund manager in New
York who often buys and sells big chunks
of companies told me that he said before
Brad Katsuyama the main character of the
story came into his office he thought he
had an insider trading issue that he
went he was thinking of buying some
stock he was going out in the market to
buy some stock and the stock would move
on him that he tried to buy and he would
go up before he could buy it as if
someone knew that he wanted to buy it
and then sell it back to him in a little
higher price the that captures the
flavour front-running it's like it's and
it's it's people think learning what you
want to do before you do it and doing it
to your disadvantage
Michael Lewis is our guest his most
recent book is called flash boys of
course he's also the author of Moneyball
blindside in several other books you
might have seen him on 60 minutes last
week and that piece on 60 minutes we
have him live here on book TV to take
your calls we're gonna put the numbers
up on the screen 202 is the area code
585 three and eight zero if you live in
the east and central time zones 585
three and eight one for those of you in
the mountain and Pacific time zones now
if you can't get through on the phone
lines you can get through on Twitter you
can send a tweet at book TV is our
Twitter handle you can also make a
comment on our Facebook page
facebook.com slash book TV and finally
you can send an email to book TV at
c-span Oh our G what's your history in
the financial markets your work Lester
personal history yes it was brief it was
brief but but lucrative he the I
stumbled into a job at the now-defunct
from Salomon Brothers when I was 24
years old in 1985
and I was uh I was trained by Salomon
Brothers for six months and I spent two
years nobody called them this at the
time but I was essentially that a
derivatives expert is what I was
supposed to be I would come and bond
salesman so I learned this was when the
financial markets are starting it very
complicated and option financial options
and financial futures were starting to
become the rage and my job was to
explain them to investors so I was
taught given a crash course in what this
stuff was and would go out and
proselytize the I quit when I was went
out in 1988 and I wrote a book called
liars poker about the experience of
working on a Wall Street and then and
then it's since then I've been in an
interloper I mean in that I've written
about a lot of other things sports my
family my high school baseball coach
whatever it is I mean politics but since
the financial crisis
I found myself drawn back into Wall
Street to write a right big narratives
and they've been three the book called
the big short which was about the credit
crisis a book called bloomerang which is
about the way the crisis expected
expressed itself in different cultures
around the world and how that showed you
something about the cultures and and
flash boys this which is about the way
the stock market has evolved really
almost since the credit crisis and my
interest it was so my interesting and
this is different than when I was
working on it obviously in these books I
think are a little bit even a little
differ from liars poker but they are
what I what seems to what's happened is
that because of my history of writing
about Wall Street I've had some access
to it's really just I think fabulous
narrative stories that happen to have
merged in from Wall Street in this time
and Wall Street I think at this moment
is a really rate rich vein of a material
for a storyteller well in flash boys one
of the themes throughout here is a
federal regulation called the regulation
national market system what is at our
reg NMS what is that and where did it
come from
so reg NMS
was implemented in I think late 2007 and
it was a response to the fear of
unfairness in the market or the
possibility of unfairness caused by the
fragmentation of the market means the
stock market wasn't that long ago when
the stock market was basically the New
York Stock Exchange right and there was
this thing called Nasdaq with some tech
companies traded and you traded the
stock either traded in one place or the
other so which that's changed the stock
market is now 13 public exchanges and 40
something private exchanges called dark
pools run by Goma Sachs or Morgan
Stanley in which you can't really see
the trading participate well you could
participate in the sense that if you're
a big investor you can give the order to
Goldman Sachs and they may execute it in
the dark pool for you but you can't see
you can't see in real time how your
trade fits into the larger trade in the
marketplace
there's a lot of opacity right and and
complexity if markets fragmented and you
can't really see what's going on in it
so to protect investors against this the
SEC came up with reg NMS and Reagan ms
says that it's against the rules for a
broker who handles a stock market order
to trade outside whatever the national
best bid or offer is so let me explain
that so let's say you the investor want
to buy shares in Microsoft and the
current if you took an agglomeration of
all the market prices that were out
there of Microsoft in the 60-something
are 50 something markets there are and
you add it all up the buys buy all the
offers to buy and sell the market and
Microsoft is 29 1999 30 so some people
are willing to buy $29.99 and some
people willing to sell it at 30 if you
come in to buy the broker is not allowed
to execute your order at a price higher
than 30 so because there's there's a
there's an offer there of 30 somewhere
in the market so it was to protect
investors from being
cheated by by the complexity and opacity
of the system
the problem is with reg NMS and why this
whole story really begins with it is
that is how the best bid and offers are
calculated they're calculated slowly so
it takes a long time for all this
information to be gathered what do you
mean by slowly and talk in a day you're
talking a week you're talking to me you
know it's funny so we're talking
milliseconds we're different and they
were talking milliseconds differences
but the technology is slow nobody has an
interest in making it nobody Wall Street
has an interest in making it faster the
so that market that official market is a
stale market the people who have faster
access to information what's going on
inside all of these exchanges know that
maybe Microsoft is actually but between
the time of your market has got your
word has gone in and and and you it gets
executed the Microsoft but if it
collapsed the next millisecond and it's
down to our office re Bros a lot that
right now we've collapsed I got yeah I'm
arguing infusing collapsed so that the
high-frequency traders can now buy it
buy it cheaply and sell it back to you
at the sale price of 30 so that that's
what happens so the the meaning the
intent of the regulation was very good
it was like to stop people investors
from being screwed by the complexity of
the market the problem is the market
figured out a way to game the regulation
by creating two markets slow market that
every investors see in the fast market
that a handful of the insiders pay to
see and the further problem was once
that happened that gap opened between
this old stale official price and the
insiders knowledge this sums of money
that were made from this vast I mean I
know how many built billions of year a
year no one knows they're asked to
mister onething or they're all nonsense
the closest I've seen to something I
believe is what my main characters try
to start to calculate from the
individual predatory strategies but it's
many billions of dollars
that once those billions of dollars are
made by those traders who are paying the
exchanges for the faster faster and
faster information and who are paying
the brokers the banks of the brokers for
the the right to trade against those
orders that are kind of dumb in the
sense that they're salutely they're all
they know is the slow market everybody's
in on it the banks and the brokers get
paid a lot of money by high-frequency
traders the exchanges get paid by the
high-frequency traders the
high-frequency traders obviously get
very very rich the investors are the
system is basically opaque the investors
they have a hard time to figure out what
on earth is going on with the stock
market orders in the skin is so slight
that they don't really feel the pain but
collectively the pain is vast though we
an echo system arises and it's no one on
Wall Street has any interest whatsoever
in exposing it or talking about it and
this is why to finish this soliloquy
sorry the market the stock market has
weirdly become incredibly secretive why
it takes detectives to go and figure out
what on earth is the stock market how on
earth does it operate because people on
the inside and I mean that's like
everybody on the inside really doesn't
want to talk about it very much well
Michael Lewis one more question before
we go to calls and tweets and emails
this is about the culture of Wall Street
you quote one of your main characters
ronan as saying it's a whole industry of
BS and in reading the book i noticed
that he's a Wall Street person and he's
a Wall Street person but I noticed it
was white male and the F word is thrown
around a lot yes it is every time when I
come on c-span I'm called out about that
I admire your willingness to attack
those who use bad language they and
defend the language the purity of the
language but they but it's it's true a
lot of it not it's it's a lot of males
it's a men's it's it is in some weird
way more of a men's world than even when
I was there now somebody that's not true
but this world of tech and trading is is
ridiculously Manila I said many times
and I thought if you wanted to reform
Wall Street just get rid of the guys and
put in women for a few years
in actually the decision-making jobs the
actual decision-making job and
everything wouldn't be cleaned up
everything would be fine
that the women would not do with the men
are doing that there's something about
male overconfidence testosterone
competition that when it connects to the
financial markets is toxic but but
anyway
Rodan Ryan is his name he's Irish so a
lot of the characters in this book the
people who are kind of the radicals who
are trying to fix Wall Street are
immigrants but rona Ryan is an Irish guy
and his whole life from the age of 19
when his family removed moves him to or
16 when he moves him to Greenwich
Connecticut from Ireland he discovers
investment bankers and financial people
because that's who lives in Greenwich
Connecticut and he wants nothing more
than to be a Wall Street person and he
spends 12 13 years that's really trying
to get jobs on Wall Street and he can't
all he can get is jobs helping guys who
call themselves high speed traders get
faster by knowing the technology of that
he knows about technology he works in
telecom he knows where fiber-optic lines
are laid through New Jersey he knows
what boxes you buy to make your trades
go faster he he's a they call him speed
in a box
he's a high-frequency traders in a box
so he spends all its time trying to get
stuff on Wall Street and he finally gets
hired by the hero of the book and is
paid a million dollars a year to be kind
of a big figure on a Wall Street trading
floor after about a year he says why did
I even want to be here you know he can't
believe the mystique was so different
from the reality that he becomes almost
instantly disillusioned Michael Lewis is
our guest in Boerne from Howard Beach
New York you're the first caller hi
Bernie yeah thanks mr. Lewis writing the
book I want to point out something you
probably know all about it already but
it's been bothering me level 2 quotes
real time level 2 quotes my feeling is
that I used to be able to look at that
and make a decision as to the depths of
the market but but it changes the bids
and the ask of the sizes change so
quickly it doesn't it's become
meaningless to me in other words it's my
contention that these high-speed
computers are corrupting the information
in
sure what is he what is so when you say
you used to be able to look in and make
a decision what do you what I actually
where are you trading what are you
looking at when you look at your screen
who's I'm looking at level 2 quotes I'm
seeing the bid and the ask on size but
who's providing you with the information
what's a key trade ok ok
Bernie what do you do for a living I'm
retired
ok but you but you're an investor or
trader I used to be now anymore ok what
is a level 2 quote what does that mean
yes sir
level 2 quote is on an on an investment
screen you will see a list of you will
take a stock any stocks IBM and they
will show you a list of the orders at
different levels and often in pennies in
a hundred and a hundred dollars plus ten
cents and on the other side a hundred
and ten dollars and eleven cents and
they'll tell you how many shares are
offered on each side and I used to be
able to see that on a steady basis and
those I could digest the information but
now these numbers change so quickly the
size changes and the bids change so
quickly that the information is useless
to me
so I've stopped it's interesting there's
a big discussion here and what we you
really want is the subjects of my book
here to explain what he's talking about
because they do it better than than I
but the exchanges enable the
high-frequency traders to to use quotes
and tactically so to submit offers to
buy or sell stock not because they want
to buy it but to make the market seem
something it isn't so he would be
looking at he's talking about I think is
that high-frequency traders will spoof
the market that they will they'll make
it look like they want to buy that
there's a lot of lot of demand out there
for the shares in Procter & Gamble but
they were able to move so
in and out that the minute anybody any
personal I came was trying to act on it
it's gone so it the informations
meaningless so it's uh it's and that in
itself is I mean that's a problem
between traders in some way it's it's a
it's a acts of deception you know short
term traders trying to deceive each
other about about what the market really
is but the bigger problem spawned by
this is that the exchange is to enable
that kind of activity have to make the
exchange itself the software incredibly
complicated I mean it did to to satisfy
the needs of the high-frequency traders
in the in all the tactics they want to
deploy and fooling people into thinking
the markets one thing rather than
another
they created instability in the system
and this is why I mean I don't mean to
expand on this too much but it was one
of the things that was really
interesting to me about this story was
that one big Wall Street bank Goldman
Sachs when presented with the story that
Brad Cassie Amma the main character the
story has to tell and a choice a an
exchange that is simple and fair and
designed for with the sole purpose of
making in a creating quality among all
investors not giving it one in one
trader on the exchange and advantage
over another then goldman sachs
basically said you know this is it this
is a moment of choice for us i mean it's
a gut-check moment for us because we
actually think we the heads of stock
market trading and goldman sachs
actually think that what's been done in
the US stock market to accommodate
high-frequency traders is creating
conditions for a catastrophe and if we
don't actually make the right choice
here to try to direct the stock market
on to fair exchanges that this
catastrophe is gonna happen at some
point and we're gonna get blamed for it
and and it's all a result of like
changes in the plumbing of the market
it's that is really just to accommodate
to maximize profits for high-frequency
traders
Michael Lewis Don matter and email sin
if front-running is illegal
why isn't writing the software for it
illegal great question so I think
parties so I you asked I one of the
questions I asked my
I was writing this story was what you
always asked this question why is this
story available to be written
why isn't there being more outrage about
this subject and it wasn't that it
wasn't that nobody had noticed that like
the exchange something was weird was
happening the stock market a lot of
people had noticed and insiders had
really noticed and it wasn't it every
day every now and then someone had not
cried out about it there were there were
some gadfly's in the industry and
critics in the industry but it was it
was that people were numbed the public
generally was numbed and I think people
inside the markets were numbed by two
things one in the course of the story
the stock markets been booming so
whatever a grift there is whatever skim
there is isn't really noticeable in the
grand con in the context of a market
that triples from the financial crisis
everybody's making money so they so they
aren't thinking very much about like is
this sound'
but the second thing is his point which
is it's in between the lines of what
he's quiz question is that when it's
done by a computer people have it's not
just deniability they have a sense that
like nobody a there isn't willful human
action behind it it's like just the
computer the computer is doing it and
they also they also have a level of
complexity that's hard to parse to
actually understand the front-running
and to prove it kind of thing you
actually will need to parse the
algorithms written by high-frequency
traders so it creates a smokescreen and
it creates I think an internal morale
defense in a funny way that if you're
directing a computer to do something you
you will a person I think a human being
will direct your computer to do
something that they would never do
themselves if they were actually had to
physically do it Linda emails into you
from Norcross Georgia what do you think
of the idea of collecting a small fee
one or two cents on each stock trade and
then apply the fees generated to our
federal and state needs even the
national debt pennies would be turned
into billions of dollars by virtue of
the volume of transactions so so the
issue of taxing
- love you taxes mmm naturally is
distortive in in in a market right and
maybe this is a good way to distort the
market but as a as a solution to this
particular problem
any sort of tax is gonna have all kinds
of unintended consequences in may it may
actually you know get the bad guys kind
of thing you may you may get some
satisfaction there but it's going to
have all sorts of unintended consoles
and then I have to think about what that
tax would do there is a solution this is
what's so great about this story it's
like a choice our society is now being
presented with and it's just it's a very
small part of our society it's our stock
market but it's actually on all of our
financial markets and that that but that
mark is so important it's so reflective
of who we are and the choice is between
fairness and unfairness and this fair
exchange has been built I think it was
needed is for as the solution to the
problem is transparency is people
understanding how their stock market
ores are being handled and and people
being given a choice about which way to
direct their stock market ores in spite
of the wishes of the needs of their
brokers and if they choose whatever
market has actually been created this
fair you will gut this system you will
you will reform the system in a way say
Occupy Wall Street never would have well
are see sewage tweets into you do we
really need hedge funds and derivatives
and leveraging do we need them and no we
need love all right we need food and
water but do we need hedge funds and
derivatives and what was the other one
and leveraging leveraging them ie he's
going to the complexity right so that's
a very good this is I think a very good
point
this sort of a good useful discussion
and the broader discussion is if you
look back in the innovation that's
occurred in the financial system since
the early eighties you can see that
things were created
default swaps collateralized debt
obligation high freq specialized access
for high-frequency traders that looked
like innovation that were masquerading
as efficiencies that the band and that
we're accepted as such because one they
were very complicated to the people who
are who were doing them we're making
more money than everybody else and three
we have this metaphor in every other
kind of walk every other aspect of our
economy innovation always seems like
kind of a good thing
it is really true that innovation in the
financial sector can be malign it can
seem like it's a progress and is not
progress I would not say I would not
list as a malign influence the structure
of a hedge fund just white people it's
just a structure for a money manager to
use leveraging depending on where it is
can be useful actually but you the
problem is that we have a little bit of
develop too much of a taste for it and
we don't recognize the social costs of
it so it's so that's a problem in
derivatives well some of the derivatives
actually should have never been allowed
to be created I think I think if you
could kind of I don't know if you could
if if there could be a watchdog who had
to problem is once you once you
introduce the government in the process
you introduce a whole set of problems
but if you the you if you could wave a
wand over Wall Street and never have
created credit default swaps we would
all be better off
Michael Lewis from the CBS News site on
this story from 60 minutes I don't know
if you had a chance to look at some of
the comments that people made on the
story but here's one from Starflyer I
like 60 minutes but this piece is a croc
maybe if it was true it affects large
buyers one percenters in mutual funds
however I can limit any buy I put in by
price and if I don't get it that's fine
with me
from what I got from the show we're
talking a few pennies a share you know
we are talking a few pennies a share so
the the so let's talk about this let's
talk about what a this question is
here's what his point is the damages are
minor if there any damages at all and
the person who says that rightly
no doubt is thinking there's been
incredible improvements in my ability to
trade in the stock market because of
Technology totally true
we are much better off because of
computers in the stock market at trading
in the stock market than we were before
it was automated it's much less
expensive to trade the problem is that
instead of the benefits of the
technology flowing to investors as it
should have to customers the way I don't
know the benefits of technology flow to
people who make telephone calls and
they're incredibly cheap to make now
compared to the way they used to be Wall
Street has captured some of the benefits
for itself totally unnecessarily by
introducing basically this inefficiency
this front-runner in the market so then
the question is what's the cost of that
what is the cost of like letting Wall
Street insert itself unnecessarily into
lots of transactions between buyers and
sellers of stocks and take out a few
pennies each time well you could say
yeah for him it's not that big a deal
and he's very happy that the computer
works better than people used to work
and he's been using whatever he's losing
it's trivial to him over the market a
few pennies share it's not even that
probably is adds up to many many
billions of dollars a year so what's
that let's say it's ten to twenty
billion dollars or whatever it is that's
a tax on investment capital just a pure
tax levied by a tax on the economy
levied by the richest people in the
economy so that's offensive
but maybe it's who cares even if it's 20
billion dollars at twenty billion
dollars who cares maybe we are willing
to go that far with you if we've had a
couple of glasses of wine but I'm
already starting to get a little worked
up then I think huh what have they done
in order to to secure this twenty what
are they done to the markets to the
structure of the markets in order to
make the twenty billion dollar grift
possible they've compromised the
structure of the markets made it money
and this is a this is a collaboration of
banks exchanges and high frequency
traders they've made it much much less
stable than it could and should be
it made highly unstable we have things
like flash crashes we have IPOs going
poof we've got outages at the exchanges
what does that cost that causes a
decline in trust in the mark
that's that's that's a that gets right
at the core of capitalism the whole
thing runs on trust so what's the cost
of this well very hard to measure but I
can tell you this that it is not cheaper
for corporations to raise capital in the
stock market because it when Trust
declines it goes up so what happens then
corporations don't invest as much and
they don't admit it costs them more to
raise the capital to invest jobs don't
get created you start talking about a
broad economic effect all right let's
say you're willing to go that far and
say ah who cares a few a little bit of a
growth in the economy a little bit of
trust who cares if we trust Wall Street
etc and so so let's say we go we go that
far we are creating in our financial
system and have for now 20 years a model
of success in life that is pernicious
and is that people are able to feel like
and are celebrated as great successes
when their what their job is the figure
is to figure out how to take money
basically from middle-class people
and transfer it to themselves into rich
people so what does that do it
compromises our educational systems the
best schools in the country send people
on to Wall Street to do this it perverts
it perverts ambition it creates its I
mean at bottom it's a moral problem I
mean it it's a technical problem it's a
moral problem and this problem of and
what you get in the end is what we have
right now which is a financial system
that nobody trusts that can't persuade
anybody to trust them because they've
watched what they did in the financial
crisis and whose interests incentives
are completely out of line with those of
the larger society there are many many
good people in the financial system
great people some of my best friends
work on Wall Street they don't want that
relationship we don't want that
relationship the society can't function
if those if the interests aren't aligned
which you because then what you get is
month people with money influencing it
influencing the culture influencing
political process the direction of
regulation and it you get to beasts the
can't can't collaborate and that's the
problem we're facing
and this is a microcosm of the problem
so yes you're only losing a penny but
the story is much more complicated than
that
up next is Sean in battleground
Washington Sean thanks for holding on
you're on with Michael Lewis mr. Lewis
you were just touching on it but it
seems that conservatives like charles
murray and all the conservative think
tanks what they're doing is they project
onto poor people all of the corruption
and wickedness the day themselves are
guilty of it fifteen years ago in the
summer of 99 roger ailes was a guest
with brian lamb and i called them up and
roger ailes of course was instrumental
in starting fox news and CNBC and Russ
Limbaugh his career and all that and I
asked mr. mr. Ailes about spear leads
and Kellog about this specialist firm
that was front running the tape and of
course he blew off my question but then
five years later the SEC levied
something close to 250 million dollars
worth of fines on the specialist firms
for front running the tape so I was
wondering if you could address those
questions of um you know conservatives
projecting you know I think the country
will be surprised to know that our
nation is run by cocaine snorting frat
boys liars poker isn't turned into a
major motion picture I just saw the wolf
of Wall Street yesterday and I think
lions poker would be even better so um
and then there's this hey you know what
Sean and we got a lot of callers on the
line let's leave it there thank you so
can I run in just one particular this
other than actually wait a minute I'll
start by recommending Hollywood listen
to what he just said because I would be
great if I wrote a movie but I don't
have any control over that and the the
the thing that that one worry I have for
the story I just told it's it's kind
it's clearly caused an uproar I mean I
keep there's no more of an uproar than
anything I've ever written in my life
the only thing it reminds me of actually
very closely but it was in a smaller
sphere was Moneyball which disrupted
the world of baseball I mean you had a
disruptive on essentially entrepreneur
rethinking an environment and in this
case you have disruptive entrepreneurs
introducing reform through Mark through
the market in in Wall Street which is a
much bigger a bigger stage but my fear
is that because it because they'd be
party politicized the story that when
Eric Holder as he did yesterday
announces as they should a Justice
Department investigation that all of a
sudden it becomes liberal versus
conservative it becomes it becomes
Democrats against rich Wall Street guys
and then the Republicans line up because
they can generate campaign funds from
Wall Street behind Wall Street and find
arguments to make that a spirit maybe
spurious arguments but nevertheless less
they becomes we get back to this
poisonous sort of we're back in the
poisonous debate where everything is
zero-sum what I love about the story is
that it isn't that way conservatives
should see that this is a market
solution these people I mean the spirit
of the heroes of this book are it's a
very conservative spirit in the way
they're not looking to the government to
fix the problem they think the markets
can fix the problem I think so so then
the broader question of like who's to
blame for whether Wall Street is
properly regulated I think it's more
complicated than a party political
problem I think that it the problem is
that for a bunch of reasons Wall Street
all of a sudden started making much more
money than it used to make I'm talking
about a broad break happenin though in
the world thirty years ago and it's very
hard for a society for regulators to
regulate an industry in which people are
so much better paid in the first place
in the basement this should be says
probably some law out there that if the
the person is being regulated makes more
than ten times the regulator that the
regulation will never happen there's
something like that but it's it's an
additive that you're dealing with in
every case where regulation is called
for it is it ends up being an arcane and
boring argument between specialists and
so
smoke and dust can be thrown into that
argument by both sides and the public
can't participate it's too complicated I
mean less you're gonna spend your whole
life paying attention to that one little
regulation so it ends up being by nature
kind of backroom deal and whether you
have a backroom deal and there's a lot
of money in the front room it's par for
those backroom deals to always achieve
with this greatest society would like
them to do it to achieve Colleen
Portland Oregon hi Colleen you're on
with Michael Lewis oak TV hi you know
I'm not worried about Goldman Sachs
but I'm wondering how you can fix this
problem and not dupe the market the only
market we can invest in and not
jeopardize the portfolios of the little
guy so the market is is pretty clearly
already uneasy by made uneasy by things
that have happened in the market I mean
it's the the the things like the flash
crash the problem of confidence in just
the market structure is it's not a
problem of appearances it's a problem of
reality it's if the market structure is
inherently unstable eventually even if
people temporarily have confidence that
confidence will be shattered so how do
you fix the problem you expose the
problem
and you you and and you work with people
who have a solution to the problem and
so that's that's what this story is
about is about fixing the problem so my
people who actually figured out a way to
make the markets stable and reliable and
trustworthy and I'm not worried about
goldman sachs either because they've
thrown their weight behind it so as has
as have a number of other actors in the
market so i think that mister i feel
like i you know it's funny i feel like
like the first half of this book is kind
of depressing and when you're learning
about what actually happened but the
second half about these guys figuring
out the solution is extremely hopeful
and that the choice is now so stark
between fairness and unfairness and
there's so much noise about what they've
done he's all very hopeful somebody we
haven't talked about who is
J Eleniak off so Sergey Elana cough it
was is how I personally became
interested in telling in writing the
book and telling the story and it caught
this was this is the first time
high-frequency trading it caught my
trading caught my eye are really anybody
else's
he was a high-frequency trading computer
programmer at Goldman Sachs in 2007 2008
and he leaves goldman sachs and i think
2009 and before he leaves he mails
himself some of the computer code some
of which he's been working on some of
which he had not been working on and
goldman sachs sees that he that this
former employee he'd gone to leave quit
to go work for a high-frequency trading
firm and goldman sachs panicked and
instantly like without whether in a
matter of Moton hours days calls the FBI
and the FBI instantly arrest sergey
atlantic off and a trial was held
eventually and he is sentenced to seven
years in jail for stealing goldman sachs
is computer code and when it caught in
the end his conviction was reversed but
only after he had spent a year in jail
and what caught my eye was I'd like
three questions at once one was we've
just come through this financial crisis
with which Goldman Sachs had a lot to do
and the only person who ends up in jail
is the person that Goldman Sachs
someone's put in jail I thought that's
very strange I mean there's why so what
did he do what was that what was such a
big deal that that the PERT that that
that he deserves to go to jail but
people who help tank the entire economy
don't have any kind of kind of criminal
kind of exposure so the second thing was
that the prosecutors who went after him
said that after he was arrested he
couldn't be let back on the street on
bail because he it was so dangerous to
have someone who had access to this
computer code because the code could be
used to I can't remember the language
but the effect was like crash the
financial system you know like disrupt
markets or and fun and they said if it
lifts this code was in the wrong hands
that would happen and I thought Goldman
Sachs is in the right hands I mean so so
we're supposed to
believe that these Wall Street firms
have code that could be used to do
really bad things in the markets but
that's okay and this guy who's left in
his hands well we can't trust him we
have to put him in jail so he doesn't go
hit a button on the computer and crash
the markets so that may be curious I had
a bet finally the thing was he was this
uh engaged in high-frequency trading
which is a term which never had I don't
think it hit the newspapers so what's
that
Wall Street generates these terms and
then everybody says yeah they know what
it is but I didn't know it was and most
people are gonna Wall Street but I asked
him they didn't know what it was either
and that was clearly so valuable that it
caused Goldman Sachs to hit the panic
button they you know there was F to call
the FBI nobody does that
I mean they do that and you don't really
do that on Wall Street there other ways
to handle the problems so I started to
ask around about what what this was high
frequency trading and this is where I
stumble upon Brad Katsuyama the main
character the story because at that
point he had been wandering through the
offices of some of the most the biggest
most sophisticated money managers on the
planet and telling them how he had found
what he had found out about what
high-frequency traders were doing in
this market
and Goldman Sachs was at that time among
them and they ought they said that
people said to me look there's a lot of
noise about the subject right now
there's no one who can describe this in
2009 like this guy and I they say he
works for the Royal Bank of Canada I
have no idea why he knows so much or how
he's figured out it's insane he's
Canadian what does he have do any of
this and it led me to him and I went to
him in the first place just to figure
out whether what Sergey Atlantic Hoff
had taken with whether it was really
valuable or what it was or should he be
guilty and he helped me understand that
and he helped me understand the really
the tragedy that happened in the
judicial process which couldn't
understand any of this and the jurors
through him I mean there was no way
anybody who sat through the trial left
with an understanding of our true
understanding of what had happened but
in him explaining certain linic off he
was explaining this this thing that had
happened the stock market and I thought
my god what a story so that became
Sergey Atlantic off became a book
I mean came a magazine piece some of his
story is in the book but the real not
the guts of the story was this young man
who was trying to figure out and reform
the entire US financial system we're
talking with Michael Lewis flash boys as
his most recent book Jim Dubuque Iowa
thank you very much for your book it's
brought public attention to this
phenomenon which is been around for a
long time
wondering if these high-frequency
traders are playing any part of the
obvious manipulation of the gold and
silver markets for example or they'll
offer to sell some astronomical and
undeliverable amount of no and then
trigger sell stops and manipulate the
market lower you know on behalf of
possibly even government system this is
threatening the global monetary system
other than any permanent so so sure it
has had no idea but any interest of
trying to say something that doesn't
bore the people who are listening
there's an observation that you can't
one who is been watching the commodities
markets the foreign exchange markets the
interest rate markets over the last five
or six years can't help but making and
make and that is it is amazing how much
manipulative activity in the prices of
things has been going on are accusations
of it I mean the LIBOR scandal in London
is this a foreign exchange trading
scandal and it raises or raises a
question what do we is it is this always
been going on we didn't know about it or
are we be in this great age of
manipulation of markets by the giant
actors who now sit at the center of the
markets in the stock market being one of
those markets
and I don't know the answer to that but
I have a suspicion and my suspicion is
they had broadly what's happened in the
financial system is that technology your
computer has information technology has
greatly reduced the necessary role of
Wall Street that it isn't what it used
to make wall so you used to make money
doing standing between buyers and
sellers is not needed any
and so the firm's the actors on Wall
Street have been forced to find other
outlets for revenues and one of those
outlets is creating complicated things
the people they sell them to don't
understand and they can take the other
side and trade another may be mucking
around in markets in ways that really
shouldn't be mucked around in but I do
not know the answer is question after
all this research Michael Lewis how much
what's your understanding of the market
do you think you understand it fully no
it's so I mean the stock market I
understand it well enough to write the
story the I'm convinced that the deepest
understanding of the market is held by
the main characters of the book but it's
it's breathtakingly complicated I mean
there are so for example there are a
hundred and fifty basic different order
types now that high-frequency traders
can use to submit their their stock
market order most of which are designed
a faint nod and great perceptions that
don't not to trade to move the price
around and I don't know all of them
I know eight of them but I know enough
them to say oh my I think that one of
them is allowed is incredible so am i I
could not give you an authoritative
account of all the type order types like
it but I can give you a broad
description of what the what they do and
a few examples I could tell you this
then I know now enough about the stock
market that I know I don't really want
to know it's okay and what really needs
to happen is it needs to be simplified
to clarify this markets it's the center
of our economy it needs to be
understandable it shouldn't be a secret
it shouldn't it doesn't need to be this
complicated are you in the market yeah
absolutely I mean I my first reaction to
learning what I learned when I started
investigate the story was I would just
take some of my money out of the market
completely just so that if this calamity
that seems like it's possible happens I
don't feel like a fool for having you
know had these people tell me to watch
out for it and not do anything but I
didn't do that very very much of my
savings what I don't do is actually
bother to pick stocks or I think that's
I think it's a fool's game I'd I think I
don't know
and it's certainly for me I just don't
have the interest I don't I just try not
to lose my money so I I am in the market
in two ways I basically buy index funds
and I another version of this as I give
my money to Warren Buffett and let him
worry about me so I buy shares of
Berkshire Hathaway and I cuz I know I
figure whatever happens he will be
positioned to exploit it and and and
whatever happens he'll be able position
to defend me against it I and what I
really want to do is not think about
this I wanna think about writing stories
so that's that's how I'm in the market
bill Tucson Arizona please go ahead with
your question or comment yes I have not
read your book and but I've been
involved in the market for over 50 years
my question is regarding the
corporations that have their stocks
listed on the new york stock exchange
and other exchanges and what their
reaction is to high-frequency trading
and the feeling that their stock prices
are being manipulated by these
high-frequency traders that is a great
question if there's a question that you
know if I'd been a better writer I would
have found some way to weave into the
book because you look at the interested
parties here and and the book is framed
as a story essentially a dance between
predator and prey and the prey being the
prey as framed in the book being
investors in the market people who are
you know buying and selling stock and
holding the stock for more than a
millisecond and the predator being the
high frequency traders but it is true
that this is I mean it is there's
another party to the transaction who
never you never hear from and probably
should hear from and that is like the
real economy out there the purpose of
the stock market is to channel
investment capital to people who can put
it to productive uses all its nonsense
has nothing to do with that it's a lot
of unnecessary financial intermediation
so how do how does some corporation feel
about its stock I can tell you the
people at face book we're not happy
about their IPO I mean I know I've
talked to people about that kind of
thing where the glitches were so obvious
that they're just they throw up their
hands and they say how can it be like
this but
I think that's a constituency that that
needs to start to speak up to go to
Capitol Hill and say look this mentally
or this mucking around in the market
it's not maybe it may be in the dollars
turn how much dollars these guys are
taking out that may not be the big deal
we need this market to be sound and
stable we need our stock prices to feel
like that they're reflecting something
and and and I so this is a long way of
saying it's a part of story I just never
got to I never actually went and
interviewed corporate executives about
how they felt about these people mainly
around the stock prices my guess is in
most cases they don't know about it then
I think they're kind of they're not that
aware of it it's not it's not high on
their list of concerns they're busy
running their business all right but
maybe now they'll get interested John
Madison Alabama hi mr. Lewis I certainly
appreciate hearing what you had to say
today and what you've done about your
book question I've got is with the
Federal Reserve and the US Treasury and
all and and I'm trying not to be
political like you said earlier - I
agree with you about that but with all
of the things that in the money that's
being put in by our government how is
this impacting that and then is this
making it more unstable or is that the
anyway but if you get the gist of my
question I think I do I mean I think
that the question is is the the stimulus
that has followed the financial crisis
creating instability in the financial
markets and the stimulus takes many
forms it's zero interest rate policy by
the Federal Reserve its quantitative
easing it's it's it's buying bonds and
the market trying to try to lower
long-term interest rates to stimulate
active economic activity this is a big
big discussion and everybody will be
stupider who's listening if i dilate it
on it for too long I mean I but you what
you need is a panel of economists to
disagree with each other so everybody
can see that nobody knows the witch I
mean what's clearly true is that the
stock market is a huge beneficiary of
this you know
of easy money and it also seems sort of
true is that for some time now the
Federal Reserve in my view has spent too
much time worrying about levels in the
stock market that I feel like government
policy seems to respond to stock market
levels as if keeping the stock market up
is it actually a goal rather than
something that should just happen in
summer should be should go where it goes
kind of thing does it contribute to
instability it certainly doesn't in any
direct way play into the story of market
structure that I'm telling so I would
say no and I but I'd also add that the
problems that say Ben Bernanke faced
when the financial system basically
collapsed in 2008 were I mean the
decisions they made to deal with the
problem with money was I think a very
whether it was whether was alt Cruz
ultimately right or ultimately wrong I
think was a very brave decision I think
was probably right in that given that
the government it was not gonna they was
not it was paralyzed it was the one way
to source prevent a depression from
happening and everything that happens
after that is second a secondary concern
so I actually think Ben Bernanke's an
American Hero I do I think what that man
did is incredible and he's taken all
kinds of grief and I've said nasty
things about him I'm sure I made it
bothers me a little bit he didn't see
the subprime crisis coming but I think
given the hand he was dealt to play he
did what he could and I think a lot of
people would have done the same thing
knowing what he knows but anyway that's
all I'm saying do you foresee a
class-action suit at some point given
what you've written hey mol Zeus I just
want you to spare the problems be fixed
right you don't like what the that's
like I hate this zero-sum bickering
between political parties you just what
people actually in a room all I want to
is fix the problem right and that's what
these guys are here and they've given
you a solution here's here's the
solution problem let's just do this and
let's not worry about lynching people
going figure out the name
the high-frequency traders who've done
all this like embarrassing people on
national TV it's just not necessary the
more that there is they're less likely
there's a solution because the people
who have been perpetrating the problem
feel like they're really exposed I think
it's sort of like let's just fix it do
you think Congress and the FCC have the
technical ability and knowledge to look
at this problem yes I actually do I do
now of course and this question is is
the money that's funneled into the
process by the people who are making
lots of money for these advantages on
the exchanges going to overwhelm the
debate I mean what you will see is a fog
machine in Congress and a fog machine
inside the SEC with lots of numbers and
data that actually don't mean very much
or false or whatever but it will be an
argument against doing anything but my
hunch is that now the problem is being
is exposed and the way it's been exposed
that the problems can be dealt with
actually the regulatory process can do
what it things it needs to do which
isn't necessarily to introduce one new
regulation we've seen what happens when
they introduce regular very well-meaning
regulation I think the two things that
people in Congress and who are concerned
with this issue and regulators should
keep always keep in mind is that
everything should be in the direction of
increasing transparency I mean genuine
transparency not theoretical
transparency but people will actually
know what's happening rather than if
they dig through 800 documents and read
the fine print don't know it and so
actual transparency and to being very
sensitive to the incentive system
they're creating in the financial
markets with what they do because people
are just responding to incentives I mean
that's what's the story of Wall Street
in the various crises we've had is
people just like answering the call of
incentives and when the essentials are
bad the behavior is bad you're not going
to change the behavior unless you change
the incentives and finally Michael Lewis
I was a little confused by the last
chapter and I just did we don't need to
tell everybody what it is they can pick
up the book flash boys and read it for
themselves is the last chapter are you
previewing your next book are you
previewing bigger better faster so
there's something else so the
Ken's the it's gonna take a long time to
get to finish the Bellamy just briefly
the book ends with me on a bike ride
riding along a fiber-optic cable that
was laid between Chicago and New Jersey
to cut off two milliseconds in the time
a signal traveled for high-frequency
traders cost 300 million dollars no one
knows why that Lane I mean they let no
one who was around that line being late
knew what it was purpose was this thing
is it's like a beast underground and
yeah I was I went riding along it on a
bike and see while I'm riding on the
bike there's a newly constructed chain
of microwave towers hovering on the
hills in Pennsylvania over the line and
those microwave towers are there because
they're able to move a signal a couple
of milliseconds faster than this line
that was put in three years ago and the
mystery is who did that so I ride up to
one of the towers and I list the number
the FCC number on the tower and I say go
figure it out there's an interesting
story about who did this and why it's
not my next book but at the bottom of
this story is is the question do people
want to know enough to go and find out
how our markets work and it was just a
challenge to the reader go on the
internet you can figure out what's going
on here subtitle of Wall Street revolt
flash boys is the name of the book
Michael Lewis is the author's